yeah so you were filming how many days
had you actually been filming before you
got shut down on Deadpool 35 days oh so
you were really into it like we we were
exactly halfway through filming Deadpool
and then we stopped can I ask you was
there any consideration in the filming
in your first 35 days knowing that the
strike might happen where you wanted to
shoot
scenes that had VFX so you could get
those done do you know what I mean yeah
of course I do that would have been
smarter than I am that would have been
so Savvy but I guess maybe like others
in our industry I somehow thought this
strike this second strike would be
averted uh and then suddenly it was upon
us and I had to send several hundred
people home and uh and they're still
waiting to come back to work so I'm just
really I'm I don't use this word lightly
but I am yearning for a resolution that
feels fair and Equitable and gets this
industry back to work I know I have to
rap with you but I'm gonna do one
follow-up on Deadpool uh because people
don't know much about it can you tease
anything about the the movie in terms of
what it's about I'll just say that it
very much leans into the fact that this
one is
Deadpool and Wolverine this one is much
more of a two-hander than either
Deadpool movie has been it's still as
I've told you raw audacious R-rated very
much so but you have two major movie
stars together in a movie playing their
most iconic signature roles that is
director heaven and so the story the
tone the movie itself leans into that
gift of having Deadpool and Wolverine
co-starring in a movie for the first
time so uh we're definitely not running
away from that